welcome back to the stage the samsung
stage on the final day of e3 i'm cam
robinson and we are about to see some
hyrule warriors which was announced just
the other day on the nintendo press
conference it was i thought it was a
great conference actually but i'm joined
by three lovely guests introduce
yourselves who are you welcome to my
stage
um i'll introduce well i guess myself
first um i'm reiko ninomiya i work in
the treehouse at uh nintendo of america
okay and next to me is mr hayashi he's
with uh tecmo kawaii games yep and next
to him is aj ajayanuma with nintendo of
japan recognize you for the press
conference both of you in fact famous
famous well we've actually got a live
demo of hyrule warriors that we can run
so i think we'll just cut straight to
that and um we can just throw some
questions you can tell me what's going
on that'd be fantastic
here we go in fact so um
uh one thing just right off the bat i'd
like to say so here you see um princess
zelda she's playing
sarah back there is playing as uh
princess zelda there are many playable
characters in the dynasty warrior series
and in hyrule warriors that is the same
is true
she is kicking ass so tell me a bit
about the combat i mean it's like you
know as with dynasty warriors you're
just being like flooded with enemies but
tell me just about the combat in general
and how is uh how is um whoever's
playing how is she kicking so much ass
here what's her what's your tactics
uh so you're right the the um
kind of what has made dynasty warriors
what it is
what it is is the ability to as a as a
character take down many enemies with
one fell swoop and just have like this
explosive action um and just experience
how good that feels um and this time um
in working with mr onuma um and nintendo
we've been able to kind of place
elements of the zelda the legend of
zelda universe uh in this space and you
know you can play as characters from the
game and you'll even see um you know
elements from the game that we think
fans will really really enjoy it's a
celebration title we're calling it to
celebrate legend of zelda and it's fans
fantastic so yeah let's think a bit
about that actually so and what
what are really like hardcore zelda fans
gonna gonna get from from hyrule
warriors what's gonna really make them
excited about this game
um
you know i really really enjoy the
ability to you know use these uh play as
these characters you normally can take
down all these enemies all at once um
but
you know we've um we've they've also
added other elements from the game so
like the treasure chest you know the
treasure chest is such an important part
of the legend of zelda experience it's
that sense of accomplishment you get in
getting to that the treasure chest but i
you know you can also see other
characters who normally don't open the
treasure chest open that treasure chest
so they've taken the experience that
fans have you know kind of come to love
in legend of zelda and really expanded
upon it
so um i saw on screen there that was
other characters so i saw link running
around so is how many players can play
at once in hyrule warriors
this time we've added a co-op a
two-player mode um that
players can play locally um and one
player will use the tv screen and the
other player will use the screen on the
gamepad right gotcha fantastic how about
characters now so you mentioned you know
you've got a ton of characters from the
zelda universe so you can play
characters you normally wouldn't get to
play as so who have we got how many
characters are are playable in in herald
warriors
so so far at this e3 we've announced
four of them so you've got link you've
got princess zelda you've got impa and
midna from the twilight princess world
and there's many many more i can't give
unfortunately more information than that
but
i completely understand great well um
what i'd really love to know is um what
is different then about about hybrid
warriors from from dynasty warriors what
have you
what is this game giving you the
opportunity to do slightly differently
i know
the fundamental gameplay is still uh
will be familiar to dynasty warrior fans
um and but we've included essential
elements from zelda one of them being
the l targeting
that's something that zelda fans are
used to doing they'll probably want to
do it in this game as well so we've made
sure to include that
in addition you'll see here king dodongo
character from the legend of zelda
so we've pulled in you know these these
uh
parts of the zelda
experience these essential parts of the
zelda experience and brought them into
this world
okay so let's talk about the combat and
get and get some detail about exactly
how that works so i mean how many how
many buttons are you using um how do you
chain attacks
so in the dynasty series uh we have
there are several buttons you can use
but they're like just to simplify it
weaker attacks and stronger attacks and
you combine these to you know develop
combos and it's
the more you play the more you're you'll
power your character up and you'll kind
of open up more combos that you can
start using to defeat stronger and
stronger enemies and each character
actually has their own combination so
i'm hoping that players will experiment
try the game out experiment and find the
one that works for them
so let's let's think about the enemies
actually so obviously there's lots of uh
individual warriors who are fighting you
but there's also bosses right so what
can we expect and from like big boss
battles in hybrid warriors
so boss battles um the way they work is
so in legend of zelda typically you'll
come across the boss the doors will
close and you're in a room with the boss
um but in this one the boss will appear
in this large battlefield that you've
been battling on and they will just go
crazy they'll move wherever they want um
and they'll attack you they'll attack
actually the other enemies on the field
um so that's a little bit of a different
take on the boss battle but
what's what we've brought in from the
zelda series is
you need to find that hint that hint in
that boss so you have to create your
strategy right the weak point exactly so
you have to develop your strategy so
that that's that zelda is you know being
really strategic in your boss battle
that element is still
still there so like what is what
opportunities is this kind of game
giving you guys as developers to really
i really have fun with the zelda kind of
world and kind of mess with it and do
things a bit differently maybe well so
yeah what kind of what kind of things
have you done differently with zelda
that this game has allowed you to do
it
you know when
everyone on the the development team
actually grew up playing zelda you know
we grew up really loving zelda's you
know some for some of us it was our
first gaming experience so you know we
had a lot of um we were very nervous
about taking on this challenge of kind
of you know taking that franchise that's
so history and has you know so many
people who love it um and
so we were a little bit reluctant um to
change kind of those essential pieces
that people have kind of known and loved
uh have grown to know and love so
actually when we when we approached mr
onuma with our first concepts he said no
do away with all that i want you guys to
take you know what you know of this
because he also had a sense that they
would stay faithful to the series as
well but he told us just to he gave us a
lot of freedom to explore and experiment
with these characters and these items
and the different uh parts of zelda that
we wanted to use um so
initially we were maybe overly cautious
but now you know we've kind of taken
those walls away and now we're playing
around and really having a great time
with it fantastic so um obviously it was
just i just announced just the other day
but when can we expect uh hyrule
warriors to be available um when when
are players of the wii u gonna be able
to get on this
car
um
it'll be released in north america in
september so i'm hoping that everyone
looks forward to playing fantastic we
talk a little bit of time so what i'm
going to do is just open up to the
viewers at home and see if they have any
questions for the guests so guys if
you're watching at home and you do have
questions the best way to get them to
these guys is to tweet at me at cam
fraserob and i will ask away i will be
the conduit for your questions
um so i mean where are we in the game
here the section where we're watching is
this early on
um
this is actually fairly early in the
game it's high rule fields
and this is actually though a version
that we created especially for e3 so
there's some elements that we customized
for the show floor and complete people
playing on the show floor
and then so we hear you say you
mentioned we're in this kind of high
so what do you call it high high real
meadows that we set uh field harold
right okay so what other type of
environments
will players be able to do battling
it
yes there's a lot please look forward to
playing them okay okay fair enough well
i've actually got some questions from
twitter so i will ask them to if that's
okay
okay so this here's a big one um i got
feeling i know what the answer is going
to be but uh alex has asked question
will we see dynasty warriors characters
make appearances in the game or other
nintendo characters
foreign
so currently the collaboration is
limited to zelda um so right now the
plan is just to limit it to the zelda
world and and you know things that the
zelda fans will enjoy
but you know it we'll see how this one
goes and and
um i'm hoping that people look forward
to more news in the future so i can
imagine that i'm just going to speculate
but i can imagine that the amiibo
feature could maybe be a thing here you
know you put mario on your we your
gamepad and he's in
that could be that could be quite
exciting that's just an idea for me but
anyway guys thank you so much for coming
on stage it's been an absolute pleasure
and to see hyrule warriors in action has
been great so thank you very much and uh
thank you really appreciate it enjoy the
rest of you e3 make sure you get a
chance to walk around the show floor and
relax and guys now don't you go anywhere
we're gonna um be back on the stage
where the game that i am really excited
about is elite dangerous we're gonna
have david braden the creator of the
original elite on the sofa here with me
we're gonna talk science and space it's
gonna be great but in the meantime we're
gonna go actually now and have a look at
how lisa got on with the omni treadmill
she spoke about on the stage just a
moment ago don't go anywhere